one of the most compelling but
ultimately overlooked stories of the
2018 season the Eagles finding the gas
pedal after Carson Wentz was out for the
year with a back injury Nick Foles comes
in they get to the postseason they knock
off the Bears and they gave the Saints
everything they could handle in the
divisional round they were up 14 nothing
driving late down 20 to 14 the
opportunity to go ahead is lost when
Alshon Jeffery drops that ball it's
picked off and that's it for the Eagles
it ends their season what if Wednesday
Chris what if that ball is not
intercepted what if that drive continues
first of all how does the game end
second of all how does the season end
and third of all who's the quarterback
of the Eagles right now yeah different
layers to this one well I almost I want
to ask you here well you know okay so
we're gonna play what if Wednesday I
mean come on we're not gonna say they
lost the game if they want you know al
Shawn Jeffery caught the ball it's not
the next play there's no so yeah of
course right for this for the sake of
this purpose yeah the Eagles win this
football game and then whoa go back to
the Rams go out to LA you know Mike
right a place where they went just a few
weeks before that and beat the Rams on
Sunday Night Football so that would have
been a scary scary matchup for the Los
Angeles Rams and yeah I'm not so sure
the Eagles don't go out there and pull
that game out once again and end up back
in the Super Bowl with a rematch of New
England and Philadelphia and I'm not so
sure Philadelphia really doesn't match
up and not to say the Rams didn't match
up with the New England Patriots but I
think Philadelphia would have been more
of a pain in the butt for the New
England Patriots to play and deal with
than the Los Angeles Rams ultimately
were just because they were a little bit
more basic in their game planning and
this is what we do and here it is and
try to stop it and the Eagles aren't
that way I do think the Eagles would
have had a good chance to get to the
Super Bowl I don't believe they would
have won it kid I mean it would have
been amazing to have both teams back the
following year yeah and and to put the
Patriots in the position where
they quite possibly would have lost two
Super Bowls in a row to the same team
that would have been something but I
just think regardless of what happens in
the NFC Championship game because it
wouldn't have been easy for the Eagles
to go back to LA and beat the Rams
actually knocking them in December right
but just getting there I think at that
point you have a much more difficult
decision to make on whether or not you
keep Nick Falls and and I think the
Eagles had to keep one quarterback and
move on from the other
I don't think keeping both would have
made sense I think it would have been
too many issues in the locker room but I
think the lift that falls would have
gotten from the locker room if he wins
that game in New Orleans takes down the
number one seed in the conference that
is the kind of lift that carries him
into the starting job and I think
compels the Eagles at that point to take
what they can get for Carson Wentz and
move on I mean I think it should have
been a closer question than it was
anyway look if they win that game it's
not a question Falls is your guy and
Carson Wentz gets traded to the highest
bidder yeah I hear you you know I mean I
thought about it too what is that line
of demarcation to go oh this would have
made the Eagles ownership in front of
office people huddle up and go okay it's
time for Plan B we got a we got to
figure out Carson Wentz is out of here
we're keeping it close I would have said
they have to get back to the Super Bowl
you're saying NFC Championship game my
original thought was the Eagles get back
to the Super Bowl and the game is at
least competitive I don't even say they
got a win but if it's competitive
yeah I'm I'm with you there I think
they're gonna have a hard time saying no
you know Nick Foles is not our starting
quarterback I think we would have had
riots in the street in Philadelphia if
that were the case so you know I'm with
you along the same lines of thinking
there I guess I just think it would have
took one more win to get there and just
think if they had won the Super Bowl for
the second straight year there's
absolutely no way you can let Nick Foles
go right and you I just I don't know
that you can keep both guys around
because anytime that question of foals
comes up I think most people think okay
you pay the 25 million under the
franchise tag and you keep him around
for another year because Carson Wentz is
making far less than that so you can
make it work for one more year right but
what's your point to make it work for
one more year at some point you have to
choose a guy and your backup is a
two-time Super Bowl winner and possibly
two-time
bowl MVP and he's number two and you're
paying him 25 million a year I think
they had to choose one of the other they
ultimately did choose Carson Wentz but
that's that's an interesting question
we're between beating the Saints and
winning the Super Bowl do you flip the
switch and go with Falls I think beating
the Saints would have been enough for me
but and frankly I think playing the
Saints as close as you did should have
been enough I just think there's a point
where you set aside X's and O's and you
say as we said throughout January whence
is the better quarterback but the Eagles
are the better team when Falls is
playing and I think they're still
holding out hope that they can take
whatever it is that foals did and get
Wentz to be that same guy and combine
his skills with whatever it is whatever
that magic is allowed the team to be
better under Falls yeah I hear you well
and I think we'll give them the
confidence to make that type of decision
and go know will go with Carson ones
here as they've seen that a little bit
you know the year they did win the Super
Bowl the way they started that season
the first 14 weeks of the year I think
they saw enough there where they said oh
this was a special year Carson Wentz was
special you know could have been the MVP
I you know and two another thing I'll
tell you this this is a little bit of a
pet peeve of mine at times because this
goes on a little too much to me in the
NFL and you kind of brought it up where
you know too many times when the backups
come in coaches refocus and figure out a
game plan that works for the team oh we
got to help out the backup you know he's
not as good so we gotta finagle more
plays to figure it out to make it work
and I know I had this happen in my
career I got I got hurt with the spleen
right and we weren't playing very good
on offense and we were kind of doing the
same things we had done the year before
and our playoff run I got hurt I came
back to meetings you know 1012 days
later and I went damn well what the hell
are all these plays who the weather all
these plates come from why weren't these
plays in the damn PlayBook when I was in
the game I don't understand that and
that to me it goes on throughout the NFL
and you know I guess I'm just I'm
renting about something that I just wish
teams would help their starters guys
like in Carson Wentz his situation at
times and and not always curtail to the
lesser talent that way you know there is
more angle to this
what if that we need to consider because
if the Eagles had decided to keep Nick
Foles and trade Carson Wentz it's
entirely possible that that very
memorable Doug Marrone press conference
when he says Nick Nick who would have
been Carson Carson who because look at
John Dee Filippo
offensive coordinator in Jacksonville if
foals isn't in play then Carson Wentz
becomes the next quarterback of the
Jacksonville Jaguars think of how we
would be regarding the Jaguars right now
if whence was the quarterback and you
know as as I put down my Nick falls
pom-poms I think about Carson Wentz is
the Jaguars quarterback and I feel a
little more strongly about the Jaguars
than I do with yeah well you know I
think in your heart of hearts we loved
what Nick Foles does we liked his play
we know he brings a certain you know era
of confidence and calmness to a football
team that we know he can deliver in the
clutch but I think in your heart of
hearts and what you've seen with your
eye on TV that you've seen Carson Wentz
at his best and when oh that was pretty
special so it can get you excited and
I'm sure that's why Philadelphia drafted
of the number two and it's kept him
there big question is Mike what would it
have taken to make a trade happen with
the Eagles cuz they didn't have to act
desperate in this situation if they
decided hey foals is our starter and
Carson Wentz is the backup here because
they're not paying him a ton of money I
I think that it would have taken the
Jaguars first-round pick probably right
and maybe a little bit more but at a
minimum that 7th overall pick to get
Carson Wentz and you know what let me
just clarify one thing yeah because my
concern when I think of the Jaguars and
Wentz versus the Jaguars and foals
the reason I'm more excited about Wentz
on the Jaguars is I'm not sure that what
Falls did in Philadelphia is immediately
and automatically transferable to
another team I hear hoping it is right
right
whence whence is wence no matter where
you put him we've seen Falls with other
teams and it wasn't good yes
what will fold magic whatever it is that
brought that team together will it work
in Jacksonville i I don't know and again
I hope it does but that's why I'm
hesitant about foals versus Wentz and it
made me think wait a minute I've just
I've just painted myself into my own
corner
I still think the Eagles better team
with foals Jaguars we'll find out but
definitely would have been better with
Wentz because whence is gonna be great
no matter who Wentz plays for I think
I've I think I painted myself out of
that queer dude no I know what you're
saying you're trying to say you know
whence is really talented and you can
put him in about any system and he can
make it work because of his athleticism
his strength is running you know
throwing on the run
Foles even though we know we can make it
work yeah has to have a certain system
or formula around him to really bring
out the best of Nick Foles I mean he's
got great size he's a he's a really good
you know
rhythmic thrower of the football he got
an overpowering thrower but gosh she's
got great anticipation and he's fearless
in the pocket and that's what you love
about Nick Foles and I do think that the
Jacksonville Jaguars can can kind of you
know emulate the formula that the
Philadelphia Eagles had anyways I really
do I mean I think with Doug Marrone you
know as the head coach they're gonna
continue to run the football and be that
way and John Dee Filippo is gonna bring
the RPO packages and some of the
play-action passes that Nick Foles has
been comfortable with to wear yeah I
think this could be similar aspect or
similar style of football from the
Jacksonville Jaguars that we saw with
Nick Foles and the Eagles and and one
last thing if the NFC Championship game
is Eagles Rams that means it's not Rams
Saints that means that the story of the
offseason fixing pass interference
fixing replay and everything that goes
along with it
quite possibly doesn't happen so yeah
that I'll tell you the other thing I
thought about is Brandon Brooks the
really good guard for the Philadelphia
Eagles remember he tore his Achilles
tendon during that Saints game and that
would make me worried when you got to go
to LA the next week they did have to
play Aaron Donald and sue who was kind
of hitting his stride finally there at
that point of the year yeah that would
have concerned me a little bit in that
matchup
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports